Android Studio 3.3
It is now available for download on the stable channel.
Used with version 3.3 is Gradle's Android plugin.
In this release we have provided
Features previewed this year, including a navigation editor,
New tracking options for the analyzer,
Building system improvements, as well as lazy task configuration.
The navigation editor allows you to create targets,
Define parameters and specify transitions between them.
If you are using a navigation architecture,
Then be able to view the entire application process
It is a major improvement.
You can link them by drag and drop.
And operate for each user
Specifies the type of conversion.
The analyzer now allows you to
Run API 26, or a later device
Select the data collection level for real-time memory allocation.
You can choose either full mode or simple mode.
This can improve your application performance during analysis.
To help you get closer
Real user experience.
With the CPU Analyzer you can view each frame
The time rendered on the UI thread.
Profiler highlighting
Frames longer than 16 milliseconds,
Lets you easily recognize when the UI doesn't work.
If your app uses an outdated API,
Android Studio is now available for you
More detailed program debugging information.
You need to add this line of code to
Gradle file to enable this option.
Reducing construction time is our constant focus.
When using an annotation processor,
We have improved incremental Java compilation.
We also added a new code scaler, R8, preview
It is faster than ProGuard.
It doesn't even require any code changes.
Try adding this line of code to the Gradle file.
If your project is configured with multiple build differences,
IDA will prompt you to sync only the current build.
This saves you time.
You can manually enable it in the Experiments menu.
The Android Gradle plugin now uses the lazy task configuration API.
This avoids creating in the Gradle configuration phase
The cost of the unused task.
The application package now fully supports instant applications.
You can create an instant app from the same project
And the installed application.
It makes it very easy to split the application
And reduce its size for a better user experience.
To deploy an application as an instant application,
Please edit the Run configuration and enable this option.
Enjoy Android Studio 3.3.
We are always watching the feedback you gave us on the bug tracker.
You can do it on the Canary channel.
Test the latest build of version 3.4.
Goodbye.